this [ __ ] ain't real I'm so scared my
name is Matt and ever since I saw that
episode of freaks and geeks where they
replaced the keg with non-alcoholic beer
I've been curious if people could
actually tell the difference between
shitty beer and non-alcoholic beer so I
got three groups of my friends to try my
own version of a non-alcoholic beer
challenge and I surprised one group with
two non-alcoholic beers just to see if
anyone could tell the difference
which we discuss so I got the duck when
I left yeah yep mm-hmm
this is like some some hops I hear I
smell okay oh my try snoring I gotta say
I'm immediately distrustful of the
delight one yeah I feel like my instinct
does that lit darker one is has alcohol
in it let me tell you for sure this one
okay only four years okay let me fill
mine first this was kind of lemony yeah
it's this smells like a sticky floor yep
what does it smell like like this was
like gasoline
I can't tell based on smell yeah I think
I detect a hint of hops yeah Cheers
[Music]
okay it's very deceiving beer you think
this would taste like there'd be a lot
more flavor to but for me and he's gonna
plain very bad very bad
that's not booze that's not beer there's
no way yeah yeah I didn't get a lick of
hops I'm not getting I'm searching for
hops here yeah it makes me feel like
they put food coloring in it to make it
feel hearty I have no clue what the fake
beer is and I can say that with full
confidence this is just like nothing
I've ever [ __ ] with in my life
you were really sipping that one so
that's alcoholic cuz I feel like I don't
really like either of these these taste
very similar and I wish you knew - this
is a trick which side of your mouth is
more drunk that's how you could tell but
he's open at the same time this has like
a watery aftertaste and this one feels
like it's there's still something on the
tongue I really like this is the
druggist I've ever been on no beer that
tastes like water really like that I
literally can't even stomach this to be
honest have you told me it is disgusting
I'd be so upset now because I'm leaning
heavily towards this is the real beer
and this is the non-alcoholic one and I
think I'm very I want to guess for you
you're gonna guess I mean cuz I'm Erika
B's a hundred percent fake definitely
correct in this guess this is the fake
one this is the real one I think this
one's alcoholic I think this one isn't
this is alcoholic
this is water no I'm still
see goddess oh my goodness
yo bear she's help she doesn't put the
other one we are like those freshmen in
high school I feel like you just sold me
oregano we are experts you know what
beer tastes like if it smells like a
college bar it's probably gonna be your
best bet
where did you get that our camera
[Music]